Kodak Black and 21 Savage have [__]
beef dude the day has come I hate that
they have beef they're both really great
guys and it sucks that they're having
beef let's see what they have to say you
to say 21
Savage 21 to be to be straight VI on the
SG twice type
[__] sniper G slaugh ggh snip whatever
[__] or whatever saying but I I remember
a point time like [__] up about me
like some [__] like you the
last [__] like that like stay on like
all that good [__] all that other [__]
and then I I don't know that saying
Drake Drake just got a certain like
little effect that he do to
[__] and
[__] after the album together and [__]
like that it was just like hey hey dude
hey dude come on
hey hey
man try a little bit you know what I'm
talking about Su with consonant you got
those what we going to
do with with that Drake Drake kind put
all together my hey guy
dude did you ever have
parents did you have teachers did you
ever have
someone like if I'm friends with
somebody like that I go like this oh my
God buddy look you got you got to you
have to you have to start talking better
you know what I'm talking about like who
are the people in his lot they're just
going like this
yeah all of a sudden [__] just
felt like
saying oh
mother that
[__] [__] like you made this [__] like
you like you vocalize it for real for
real on the ground on the on the
internet like you never live
that just waking
up
[__] and the [__]
Theo like that's what he said hey this
is
beef imagine hearing that and going like
this oh that [__] crossed the
[Laughter]
line when you're talking
about we've got an exclusive with uh
Kodak Black hey who who you to say f 21
Savage here we go we got an exclusive
interview with Kodak Black Let's Play a
clip of some of the uh some of the stuff
that he had to say kind of incindia when
it comes to the the rap game why don't
you have a
look be straight iing we VI on the SG
twice type
[__] sniper G slaugh gaugh SN okay you
know imagine my dad listening to that so
here's 21 Savage's response which should
just be
what get response to 2 just goes what
but his response here cuz I did a
goddamn album after I did a album with
Drake I switched
up come on
bro first of all falling
asleep falling asleep falling
asleep what what what what supposed to
switch like what supposed to change like
dude these two
guys one just woke up and the other
one's falling asleep
dude
unbelievable
dude I ain't grow up with you [__] I
don't know you like that like you rap I
rap I always supported you and
[__] I [__] with your movement like I
[__] with you what you had on what you
had going on
like talking about switched up you get
in your feelings cuz I'm on
clubhouse and they ask me I can't even
believe I'm doing music dude you should
never have if you have if you have beef
with somebody never say
Clubhouse you
know
hey
children you know what I'm saying meet
me at my tree house dog after dinner if
you allowed outside it get dark early
remember weak ass [__] on [__]
lie you I'm
clubhous that's it you know oh wait one
more here more all you had to do was say
future I I pick future over sabage you
going to this deep [__]
explanation cuz got when got oh did he
start acting funny crying how what the
what change why are they bleeping out
the bad words we can't tell cuz I said I
felt like I beat everybody who was on
the freshman cover I'm post to feel like
that [__] I ain't no [__] I ain't
going to say no nothing [__] one thing
I ain't going to ever do in my life and
say [__] can beat me in a fight beat me
at nothing I'm not saying I don't give a
damn they put me in the ring with she
kill
O'Neal
what okay but there you have it the
exclusive
interview hopefully they they iron out
this beef man